i'm a great believer that any
application of technology
um should be to solve a problem should
be to solve a human problem
um uh if uh if if the technology can
make something work
better then we should be open to it but
so often we implement technology in
places
just because it's available because
somebody else did it
um we have to suffer a real problem that
we that we want to that technology can
solve
and the amazing thing is sometimes
technology is not the best solution
sometimes leadership thinks that
technology is the best solution and
never asks the people
one of my favorite examples is a
manufacturing company
that um that realized that they didn't
know
the the loading of their machines and
who was busy and who wasn't busy
and so they spent three million dollars
on a very very sophisticated
sap system to tell them all of the
what's going on what machines were busy
what people were busy the status of any
particular job etc etc
and all of the information was available
you just had to go screens deep to find
it and here was the problem they spent
all that money
and nobody used it and so they asked the
people who actually worked on the
factory floor will you fix it
they went to the local stationary store
they bought a bunch of colored folders
red yellow green
they bought a bunch of lucite folders
that they pinned on a board
and they put the name of every machine
on the lucite board
and the name of the job in the folder
and if you're green it's because you're
on schedule
if you were red it's because uh you were
running late you needed help
and if you were yellow you weren't
working your machine was down and you
were available to do other work so you
could stand there in front of this board
that they
probably spent thirty dollars on uh and
in an instant you could see
who in the factory was working and who
was and who wasn't and who needed help
and i think that's more innovative than
simply the application of technology
and so we have to include the people who
have to use the technology
tell them the problem tell them the
solution we think will work but ask them
if they have other solutions
because sometimes the people in the
front lines the people who actually have
to use this stuff are way more
knowledgeable than the people who are
actually actually doing the purchasing